We're going to use a strategy to tackle this problem just like we've done
before. We're going to make this problem easier. So we're going to use different
fractions instead of 2/5 and 1/4. Let's use 1/2 and 1/3 instead. So I rewritten
my question down here. Before we answer this problem, let's actually predict. So
if we frost 1/2 of the cake in vanilla icing and 1/3 of it in strawberry icing.
What fraction of the cake is actually frosted? Would it be less than 2/5?
Exactly 2/5 Or more than 2/5? Draw some diagrams to help you out. Let's actually
consider a round cake. And here's what 2/5 of a round cake frosted would look
like. Notice I have my whole chocolate cake, and 2/5 of it has been frosted in
this blue icing. So, what do you think 1/2 and 1/3 of a cake covered in icing
would look like? Make your choice.